it's a crisis
well I'll ask the question sir and the
board here is quote unquote journalist
from uh CNN Jim Acosta we haven't shown
a Jim Acosta video on a while in a while
he had a North Carolina representative
Ralph uh Ralph Norman on Republican to
discuss what's going on at the border
and you tell me is Jim Acosta doing
journalism here or is he doing partisan
hackery go
it just sounds like you're throwing uh
rhetoric around with no basis in fact
yeah
no you can have you been to the Border
of course I have
you seen what's going on the rapes the
uh it's open I mean nobody can can deny
that borders and uh they've got a it's a
crisis
where I'll ask the question sir and the
booster is not open that is that is
something that that is uh peddled as a
talking point but it's not true their
their offenses their walls uh there are
border patrol agents who work on the
border
the five plus million uh that have
gotten in this country illegally uh is
not a figment of our imagination ask the
border patrol agents ask anybody down
there they're first I guess I haven't
you have not been able to answer my
question as to how you effectively do
border enforcement if you're shutting
down the government I guess but I guess
we're not going to get an answer to that
question I don't know how to say it
anymore plainly guys there is a giant
system in place to make us a little
and it is your job as a human
being not to buy the BS it really is
everything Acosta says there again he's
not a journalist does Acosta not know
that they're letting people right
through the Border uh in a costume's own
City I believe CNN where he is is in New
York City in that City he's got the
mayor saying our city is about to
collapse because of ten thousand illegal
immigrants a day a month so how is it
that they're getting there unless the
border is open like this is basic stuff
everything is due and also he's like
well we have we have a wall and fence oh
did you just come out for Trump's wall
because I remember when Trump wanted a
wall you were calling him race that was
the whole modus operandi of CNN are you
suddenly for walls and by the way not
only do we not have walls and fences
everywhere but if you open the door of a
fence people sometimes wander in and
we've shown you those videos too